And so today I'm going to
do a fairly impossible task,
which is to talk mostly
about Eastern Europe,
um,
in the interwar period.
Um,
and let me just add,
I sent around a rather lengthy list of
terms so I don't have to write on the
board and you can't see it anyway.
Um,
and I,
I'll work from that.
Uh,
so it'll help you understand,
but the big points are clear.
Um,
and the maps will help you as well.
But just a couple of things
at the beginning of their two,
perfectly obvious,
um,
that,
you know,
in 1914,
I mean,
few people could ever imagine that
they would sweep away four empires,
et Cetera,
and take the lives of,
um,
uh,
millions of people.
Um,
in 1918 in 1919,
uh,
there was,
the great illusion and the great
illusion was a held by Wilson.
Lots of other people is that worse were
started by evil people in high places,
which may often be the case.
Um,
but,
um,
that,
uh,
that the problems left by
the treaty of Versailles,
uh,
we're basically a insoluble.
Uh,
and that the 1920s and thirties,
I is basically a continuation of the war,
uh,
and that you can look
at the entire period,
14 to 45,
a as a,
as a 30 years war.
Uh,
and that Europe was in
depression basically the
entire time between the wars.
And as we'll see when I talk about
Eastern Europe and central Europe,
that has a lot to do with the instability,
the chronic instability of the period.
Now Western Europe and
the United States were,
were,
uh,
really not an in depression between a,
you know,
24 and 29.
Um,
and then the thunder comes a in 29 and
the United States as they get out of the
depression until basically
World War II instead of,
uh,
you know,
buy and that's,
uh,
the war economy helps them do that.
But Eastern Europe,
uh,
and the places where the instability
and the lack of parliamentary traditions
was so important,
uh,
is an agricultural
depression the entire time.
Uh,
and that,
um,
by 1939 in central and eastern Europe,
only one state,
Czechoslovakia,
uh,
remains a parliamentary
regime in all of the others,
uh,
the Europe of the eastern Europe of
little dictators and fascist parties and
right where,
right wing,
uh,
agrarian populous parties that didn't,
some of them didn't start out right wing,
uh,
poisoned the political atmosphere
and the treaty of Versailles.
You know,
it when they meet and
these delegations meet,
including the former president of a Yale,
a Charl or future president of meal,
Charles Cmr,
I,
within the American delegation there,
they,
they were convinced that they could put,
um,
put an end to all wars and they will
get Germany to sign on the dotted lines
thing.
We started at all.
And there's all argued next week.
And it's perfectly clear.
Uh,
that was a catastrophic mistake
because the war was Germany.
Arguably,
he had a greater war role and starting
the wars and the other places.
But this guaranteed the perpetual hot
hostility of an ever increasing number of
right wing parties at
which the most vicious,
uh,
and the most successful
would be the Nazis.
Uh,
post the very existence of the,
of the Weimar Republic,
uh,
and became what is all
explained in a minute.
A revisionist state.
The revision of state is one that wanted
to revise the treaty of Versailles
because people have their ethnic,
uh,
dominant ethnic group.
It ended up on the wrong
side of the frontier.
And if you'd fought a war that was based
upon national claim in 1914 in which
aggressive nationalism was one
of the root causes of the war,
um,
the successor states that
are created out of these,
these,
uh,
a collapsed empires,
find themselves,
uh,
with facing the reality that you could
get all the maps you wanted and you could
get all the photographers that you wanted
and geographers and bring them all to
side and bring them all to,
uh,
this fringe suburbs.
[inaudible]
knew he and the others.
Uh,
Sandra man that became,
you know,
named after the treaties
with the individual,
uh,
powers.
But,
but you couldn't draw lines around
national groups that we're going to
incorporate everybody,
uh,
within the country of their choice.
You couldn't do it.
And that becomes,
that leaves a permanent,
uh,
factor of,
for,
for instability.
And if you don't believe me,
look at the Balkans.
And in the,
in the 1990s,
which were the worst,
uh,
you know,
atrocities,
uh,
since,
a sense of death counts,
uh,
in,
in World War II and in
which ethnic cleansing and,
and,
and rape as a,
as,
as a,
as a means of waging war,
I became a reality again in which
those old hatreds had never been been
extinguished.
And so the great illusion was that
there wouldn't be any more wars.
Uh,
and in the case of Germany,
as we'll see,
uh,
that the troops who are
demobilized who came back,
they kept drilling in their basements,
the fry core,
the free core in Germany,
and that,
that lots of people,
uh,
you know,
among them,
just one of millions,
uh,
the young Adolf Hitler,
the argument with the,
the,
the view that they held it was,
was that the problem wasn't to have
fought the war in the first place,
which was a Wilsonian view of the war.
But the problem was not
to have won the war.
And the problem is how do you explain
to home that you've lost a war when your
tubes are far,
far inside,
uh,
Germany and the other,
I'm going to of my story,
but,
uh,
it's just such a complicated,
subject to all of this.
It's a little hard not to.
And the other problem was if you're
punishing losers in World War One,
uh,
you're often punishing the way that,
that,
that seems to violate the very
principle that you hope to espouse of,
you know,
each country,
each people more or less their own country
peak and the powers that become the
revisionist powers,
uh,
almost all were on the losing side.
And they're the ones that,
that by the very principles
espoused at Versailles,
the basically just simply get screwed,
uh,
and as the Hungarians put it,
no,
never.
That was their response.
No,
no,
never.
Uh,
and these,
these powers of which the most
dangerous ultimately is Germany,
uh,
of far more powerful and defeat than,
than Francis and victory basically vow
to get even not the Weimar republic.
But those people who wanted to destroy
other republic and that Eastern Europe
will be full of little of little Hitlers,
little,
a racist dictators who,
um,
are also convinced that the
next one we'll get it back.
We'll get it all back and
we'll bring it back with,
with,
uh,
a percentage of interest as well.
And increasingly appointed.
I'd better make an awhile,
uh,
that they begin to look at in the
Europe of extremes as Germany has a very
compelling model,
uh,
and the Eastern European states that had
certainly reasons to fear increasingly
if you're Germany,
but begin to see Germany is that
rather successful model and the,
you know,
the Europe of,
uh,
of the extremes as Eric
cops warm that has,
has called it is a,
it's basically basically,
uh,
if you include the Soviet
Union and if you exclude the,
which is another kind
of a totalitarian state,
uh,
and,
and if you exclude the role of the
Communist parties as a d cell stabilizing
force.
And many of these
countries is a Europe of,
of fascism,
uh,
and they just keep right on marching
because fascism part of fascism,
they're better at the fascist
or veteran describing it,
what they,
how they will take power,
marching violence,
uh,
and whom they hate than what
they will construct afterward.
But what they will construct Afro
afterward in all of these places,
uh,
will be,
totalitarian,
fascist state,
uh,
that is based upon the
principle of totally over the
top aggressive nationalism.
And anti whatever the minorities are,
particularly the Jews and antisemitism.
I becomes an important part of,
of all of this.
So the map,
the guys with the maps
and the pencils and,
and uh,
trying to drive the little,
draw a little squiggly lines,
it doesn't really work out very well.
And,
and Wilson comes back in utter defeat
and the American Congress doesn't prove
the treaty of Versailles,
uh,
anyway,
in America enters that,
you know,
a period of,
uh,
of isolationism at least until the next,
the next time around.
So that was a rather lengthy introduction
to what I was going to talk about.
So let's try to be,
um,
a more,
uh,
a specific,
specific now.
Um,
so what are their,
you know,
what are the big time revisionists states
first let me just start out with one
that didn't lose a,
but it's one in which,
as you'll see when you read the chapter,
we're fascism is first a saluted and then,
uh,
take power.
And that is Italy.
Now Italy wins.
They're open to offers,
open to the highest bidder,
and they joined in 1915 because,
uh,
because the allies can promise,
the more they pomp promising
part of the Tier Hall,
you know,
between Austria and Italy and the,
and they promise them,
uh,
um,
parts of the much of the Dalmatian coast.
Um,
and Italy went to war,
uh,
um,
well for that reason,
but also because in a country in which,
you know,
a sense of national unity
basically didn't exist.
There was a strong feeling that war
will make Italians out of all these
different people,
you know,
that's no real good reason to go to war,
but they do go to war.
Uh,
and of course they were being
systematically denigrated
by the other allied
leaders for a wolf,
all aspects of their,
of their army,
which also took huge losses.
Uh,
uh,
fighting the,
you know,
the,
uh,
Austria,
Hungarian forces.
Uh,
and so when they come to,
uh,
they come to Versailles,
Orlando,
who is their,
um,
their representative,
it's so easy.
He's the junior partner in this.
They don't pay a lot of attention to them.
And,
and Wilson says,
well,
you can't give them the two hole
because they don't have Italian.
Um,
uh,
a majority is there and they certainly
don't have Italian majorities.
And the in the,
you know,
the animation coast,
which is populated by logically enough,
reasonably enough,
bye,
bye Croats.
Um,
and so they don't get what they want.
And Mussolini who began his,
uh,
his career was a socialist.
He was the editor of Avante,
you know,
forward,
which is the socialist paper.
Uh,
he,
uh,
he becomes a,
it,
one of the originators of
fascism many period is,
you'll see in the,
in the book on the cover of
Time Magazine and eight times.
He's the guy that got the
railroads to run on time in Italy,
but only the ones for the ski resorts.
Um,
and,
uh,
anyway,
I don't have time to talk about them now,
but,
but so they're kind of
originate as power and then,
uh,
Mussolini's discourse about how he's
going to turn them into training,
into an Italian lake,
revived the Roman Empire.
And all of that has to
be seen in that context.
Uh,
but Italy did not,
I was not quote unquote,
a loser in World War One,
but rather an aggrieved winner.
And that,
I guess that's a good way of putting it.
Now the revisionist powers are those that,
that,
that last,
um,
that,
uh,
originals powers of course
no one was more revisionist.
Uh,
then,
then Germany,
uh,
and the German,
the German empire is destroyed.
And,
and,
and Germany,
I mean,
again,
this is hard to summarize all of this,
but,
uh,
Germany,
from the very beginning,
so I said,
well,
if you're going to argue that,
that,
uh,
that national ethnic groups and
where they live should determine,
uh,
should determine,
the drawing of boundaries.
Uh,
then,
um,
what the allies did to Germany,
it seemed extremely unfair
and not only to the far right,
uh,
in Germany.
Now this leaves aside the question,
and I'll come to next week,
uh,
and John Maynard Keynes,
who was a,
you know,
brilliant,
brilliant guy,
he's the one who saw that this is,
this is recipe for disaster,
the treaty of Y'all side.
And he's the one,
he said,
this is just a truth.
It's not the end of the war because if
you make Germany pay for the whole war,
based on that they've
signed the war guilt clause,
you're going to sew,
destabilize this,
this country that eventually
the right will take over.
And that's exactly what happened.
That's exactly what happened.
But to [inaudible] point of view of,
of,
uh,
of Germany,
the,
the most egregious loss that they
suffered was the Polish corridor.
Um,
if you go to [inaudible],
which is a wonderful city,
which was the story during the war,
like mostly,
most every city in Poland,
except for Krakoff,
uh,
which really got lucky.
Uh,
I can remember going to Warsaw,
Oh tone,
they come Ohad uh,
you know,
it was still,
under and under the communist regime.
And it was still,
when I was a kid,
there were still,
you could see there were there
once it had been boulevard,
the whole place was just absolutely raise
Krakow was very lucky cause cause it,
it survived.
But what they do is,
is,
you know,
a good dance gets rebuilt,
but,
but gun Gdansk was a German city.
The Polish population was extremely small.
You may know of Gdansk because
that's for solidarity began in,
in,
in 1979 in 1980.
It's an important port there
and that's where liquid lens,
I've got his start in the
whole solidary movement,
including some of my,
some of my friends who
are very young printers,
historians who are young
printers for solidarity,
uh,
in those days.
And as I've said a couple of times,
I go to pull on all the time,
uh,
for the last couple of years,
five times or something like that.
But anyway,
Gdansk in the point of
view of the Germans was,
um,
uh,
was German.
Uh,
the vast majority of the population was
German of the Polish corridor divided,
uh,
the rest of,
of Germany from East Prussia.
And it was,
uh,
was resented.
Uh,
and because of the,
by the Germans,
because of,
of there was a strong,
a German population that remained,
of course,
the Poles,
when they look at Gdansk,
they look back to when a good
dance was an important port,
them to in the Polish
Lithuanian Commonwealth.
In fact,
polls are quite insistent,
Polish a story into the
whole concept of solidarity.
I mean,
excuse me,
of,
of sovereignty that that emerged,
uh,
in the Netherlands and an England,
in early modern times was
also being constructed in,
in,
um,
in and around Gdansk.
And the other,
a big wound for the Germans was of course,
uh,
the Cha,
the checklist,
Slovakia,
because the second largest
ethnic group in the newly,
uh,
one of the successor states,
along with Poland and Yugoslavia.
I,
the first it,
I have the statistics in
what I sent around to,
uh,
were,
were checks about 50%,
uh,
Germans,
if I remember correctly,
we're 23% and Slovaks or 16%.
And the other,
of course,
or other minorities,
I mean,
they're Ukraine and Poles and uh,
and all sorts of things.
And lots of the Germans were concentrated.
The majority of Germans
were concentrated in a prog,
or there weren't as
many of them is before.
Uh,
but,
but above all,
you know,
I mean in the whole area,
the region of Bohemia and in that
region called the Sudeten land,
the Sudeten land,
Germans.
And when,
uh,
the allies capitulate to,
to,
uh,
Hitler's demands,
that,
that part of checklist of Aki.
And then of course,
he,
he munched the whole thing a pass into,
into Germany.
One of the reasons that the AAP says,
they said,
well,
maybe he's got a point,
you know,
19,
18,
you know,
we couldn't really put the people
where they were supposed to be.
And,
and there are German minor majorities in,
in,
in good percentage of,
of Bohemia.
Uh,
so maybe within the checklist,
Slovakia.
So maybe,
you know,
maybe he's got a point.
And that was an excuse.
That was a rationale for,
uh,
for appeasing them at a time
that he might've been stopped in,
which is in generals,
his generals who were
just scared to death,
that,
that there was going to be,
that the allies were going to fight
them because they weren't ready.
They weren't ready for war.
So,
uh,
Germany is above all of
the big revision as power.
More about this when we talk about,
uh,
about off Hitler,
um,
uh,
next week.
The other is a course,
um,
mass.
Come on.
Do we need to see shows?
Um,
the other big one is if,
of course I can't find him as a matter of,
uh,
is,
um,
uh,
is hungry,
um,
and so hungry loses.
I got to remember these statistics.
Uh,
it might've put it around,
but they lose if I could,
I think I remember them.
They lose 25% of the Hungarian population,
uh,
to other states.
Uh,
they lose about two and
a half and two thirds,
I should remember,
but I don't,
uh,
of the land of,
the old Hungarian domains,
uh,
when they were in Austria,
Hungary,
when they were the,
you know,
as supposedly after a 1967,
uh,
the,
the equal partner,
uh,
of Austria.
Um,
and so they lose the greatest percentage
of that Hungarian population to
Romania.
Um,
and of course,
the tensions between the Romanians,
uh,
and the Hungarians,
w were,
were,
were extremely great.
Uh,
I mean,
the linguistic differences that
are enormous because Hungarian is,
is,
uh,
is such a difficult language.
It's just an isolated language.
Uh,
in that I have a,
I have a friend who retired
here I many years ago,
uh,
who speaks 18 from,
from eastern Russian,
east European languages and literatures,
who knows 18 languages.
He knows,
like all,
mostly every European
Central European language.
I said,
do you know Hungarian?
He says,
no,
it's too hard.
Uh,
and so that,
that accentuates the sort of
isolation from the Romanians.
And again,
in 19,
in 1989,
uh,
the Gra the great ground swell against
your chest Q and as horrendous wife,
the dictators in Romania,
I began with Hungarian,
a dissidence who had,
whose families had been
generations since World War One,
a stock from their point of view,
uh,
in Romania.
And so,
uh,
when you're trying to look at each of
these countries and try to figure out why
to some,
you know,
right wing Maggot,
some of right wing dictator,
uh,
take power,
is because as in the
case of odd off Hitler,
if you say the same thing
over and over and over again,
pretty soon you get people to believe you.
And Admiral Horthy,
who was an admiral in the
Austrian Hungarian Empire.
He becomes a,
uh,
an extraordinarily,
you know,
vicious dictator and,
and,
and the egregious collaborator,
uh,
during World War II to sort
of a admiring junior partner,
uh,
of Hitler and the Nazis.
And,
and,
and the frenetic,
uh,
aggressive Hungarian nationalism,
will,
uh,
you can go a,
you can go to Budapest and
then go along the river,
the Danube river and Budapest,
and see where they've,
they've made a sad monument
over the shoes of Jews who were,
who were shot or just simply
pushed into the swirling waters of,
of,
of the Daniel by the,
by the,
a Hungarian fascists in,
in,
in 19,
uh,
44.
Uh,
and,
and again,
this is not dissing Hungarians that,
you know,
as a people obviously
not hunger in friends.
And I love Hungary.
Budapest.
It's my third favorite city.
Uh,
uh,
but,
the,
the damage done by,
uh,
you know,
the revision that's claims in Hungary
where were simply amazing and of all the,
uh,
after the Germans,
and arguably even more than Germans,
they had the most to be aggrieved about,
uh,
because losing so much of,
of their country,
uh,
awarded as because they had lost to,
to,
to other places.
Now,
the case of Austria also,
I mean,
Austria,
if you go to Vienna,
I mean at Vienna's,
it's a wonderful and a
huge musical full of broke,
broke,
broke.
Uh,
you know,
it's really a,
it's a,
it's a great city and you think,
oh,
this is an enormous city
for such a little country.
And of course,
what happens from the
Austrian Hungarian Empire is,
is dismembered.
Uh,
Australia becomes a,
a small,
uh,
and overwhelmingly German speaking state.
There,
there are very few ethnic,
uh,
comparatively ethnic minorities living in,
in,
uh,
in what was,
became Austria after,
after World War One.
It's an imperial city.
It's imperial city,
uh,
not reduced in size,
but reduced,
uh,
in,
in importance.
So Hungary,
I'm huge,
huge reasons to be extraordinarily,
uh,
extraordinarily angry,
by the,
the whole thing.
Um,
Yugoslavia,
Yugoslavia.
I mean,
they,
um,
you know,
they lose some land that they would have,
uh,
that,
that they wish that they would've gotten.
But,
but again,
Yugoslavia,
you have this tremendous,
you know,
ethnic complexity.
So in a way that that successor state of,
uh,
of Yugoslavia,
maybe some of you have or will
take evil bonuses of course this,
and he's a great Balkan,
uh,
a historian.
But the,
the ethnic complexity of course is,
uh,
is a sort of a mini version of the
Austrian Hungarian Empire were Serbs,
uh,
something like 40% of the population of,
of Yugoslavia,
uh,
between,
the wars.
And that would be really
about the percentage until
the whole thing collapses in
the early,
in 19,
uh,
nighties and with the crops,
the next,
uh,
the next largest,
percentage,
and then followed by,
by Slovenes,
who are the wealthiest Ralphie region
in [inaudible] roommate remained that
until the end.
The standard of living in Slovenia,
uh,
in the 1980s was about that of,
of,
of Italy,
uh,
where if you went far,
far down to,
uh,
to Kosovo where I've been,
you know about which,
uh,
you know,
so much it's been going on in
which is now has been been,
uh,
I've reclaimed independent
and me was absolutely,
you know,
absolutely impoverished.
So the athlete complexity is a,
it's in self there to going to be
a factor for a destabilization.
And what about Poland?
I mean,
Poland is a,
is a,
uh,
you know,
Poland had not been independent since,
since 1795 since the third partition.
And you had,
as I've already discussed
in another context,
you've got Polish intellectuals.
Uh,
you've got political militants in,
in the,
uh,
1830s,
and again in the 1860s,
who don't want to be part of Congress.
Russia.
Uh,
they don't want to be Congress,
Poland,
I don't want to be part
of the Austrian an empire.
They want to be part of Prussia.
They want an and dream of
the independent Poland.
And so,
you know,
what you have,
uh,
in,
they get,
they get their independence
in 1918 immediately.
But the complexity of course,
is enormous to there because
you've already got these ethnic,
uh,
who,
you know,
are there.
I mean,
the Germans are there.
You've got a huge numbers of Ukrainians.
In fact,
in,
in eastern Poland,
I mean,
the city's like zoom Moish were
the Rosa Luxemburg was worn,
which is a beautiful city.
Uh,
you know,
these are Polish cities.
Uh,
but the,
the vast majority of the rural
population are Ukrainian.
Uh,
they are Ukrainian.
And this was a force of a,
for quote,
unquote instability.
And of course,
they will be killing each
other off during World War II.
Uh,
and then the other minority,
of course,
are,
are the Jews.
Um,
and how many Jews were there in Poland in,
um,
in 1918,
19,
19?
Well,
uh,
Poland,
was considered to be before Israel.
Poland was really the,
uh,
the cultural heart of,
of,
uh,
Judaism.
Uh,
they're 3 million Jews living in Poland,
uh,
in the east mostly,
you know,
mostly Orthodox.
And [inaudible].
Uh,
but,
um,
when I was at,
by the way,
this is not just that,
you know,
it's a side,
but it's a telling aside,
when I was in his emotion,
um,
we were taken to,
we were taken to a synagogue
which had been turned into,
um,
uh,
had been turned into a
place where students,
uh,
the same students and middle school
students exhibited there painting.
And I asked the,
the guide who was taking,
you know,
these are academics around and
press editors and all this stuff.
I said,
well,
look,
uh,
how many,
how many Jews?
Most of the population was emotion.
1939.
And he said,
the population of his emotion,
1939 was 39,000.
He said,
how many Jews were living in as emotion?
Who would have been coming
to this synagogue in 1939,
he said 12,000.
12,000.
I said,
how many Jews live in his emotional,
Cheryl,
the others,
if they were lucky enough not to
have been killed in the death camps.
And I just reviewed a book
for the globe about the,
about the ghetto in what's no Lod z.
You know,
they were like,
had to get a file,
get out.
I'm not to jump ahead,
but the number of Jews who
survived out of the 3 million is,
it was about 300,000,
uh,
Polish Jews who I think came back
to pull them to the same time.
The point of this is that,
that these ethnic tensions,
particularly in a part of Europe were
antisemitism had been just replete,
uh,
in,
um,
I mean,
again,
just don't,
how can you not,
it's a 30 years war.
How can you not leap
ahead into World War Two?
You know,
some of the,
some of the massacres of Jews,
uh,
for example,
in,
uh,
during this horrible period were,
were done by,
uh,
by,
Ukrainians in Ukraine,
Lithuanians,
uh,
in Lithuania.
And many of you've seen
just horrific pictures.
I can't remember that we have,
is awful picture that used
to read first edition.
I don't even know if it's
in the second edition,
uh,
who were beaten to death.
A colleague of mine here,
my Darlene,
no one,
a yawn,
a gross,
wrote an important book called neighbors
about how Jews and Poles who lived in
Poland in the 1920s in
1930 [inaudible] live.
Do they live very
peacefully in one village.
And how almost without
an without ends up here,
an instigation from the Nazis who have
been happy to kill them all on a plan to
kill them all,
just simply one day started killing
them all and shot them all dead,
beat them to death,
put them in barns,
burned the barns.
And so these tensions,
these at which is aggressive nationalism,
I mean still,
I mean in Poland Manga.
Okay.
You still,
you just,
it's amazing.
It's amazing.
I mean,
there still is this undercurrent of,
of,
uh,
of antisemitism.
And I,
and I hope this being filled,
I sometimes forget.
I mean,
they may get letters from,
but,
but it's,
it's really incredible.
I was being interviewed and I'd Polish TV,
uh,
with this other guy and it was a
pleasure to announce our president.
But anyway,
because,
uh,
anyway,
but I don't speak Polish.
Um,
and,
and another time we were all
being interviewed and they said,
this guy said,
he said,
what do you think of the
Jew problem in Poland?
And just,
you know,
I was about to
kill him.
I shouldn't say that,
but,
you know,
take them out.
And not really,
but,
you know,
I was pretty mad.
And then this woman who was there,
uh,
who represents the,
the Jewish community such
as it remains for in Israel.
She said,
no,
it's just,
it's a question of language.
But when we went to one
of the Polish museums,
which is the museum of
the Warsaw uprising,
and they don't have a museum of the,
of the ghetto uprising,
they have a meeting.
We had to complain semi officially about,
about the,
how they depicted Jews
in the 1920s in 1930s.
So this is not the dump on Polish.
What is the DAP on Polish antisemitism.
But,
uh,
but not as Poland as a state,
but these tensions were,
so they're exacerbated in
world war between the wars.
Because if you've got these frenetic
right wing leaders who are aggressive
nationalists and all of these places,
and who are they denouncing,
they're announcing what
the treaty of Versailles,
who,
Romanians,
if they are Hungarians,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
You pick the nationality
and Jews most anywhere,
uh,
and it was there.
And so,
uh,
these,
these folks are often like whore.
The are preaching to the converted.
They're preaching to the converted.
And,
um,
well,
I mean it's,
it's an obvious,
sad story.
But in this review,
these revisionist powers,
all this stuff is going on.
Oh,
I know less about,
and don't have much time
to talk about Bulgaria,
but you have the same,
which was what's lost.
But you have the same kind of,
of tensions.
Uh,
Turkey was just completely,
that's arguably the harshest
treaty is that with Turkey,
because they lose much of the,
of,
or what most of what's left really
in the Middle East of Turkey.
And this gets transformed
into mandates under,
under British and French,
uh,
control.
Um,
and of course they lose as a losing power.
They lose a land to a,
uh,
they're bitter arch enemy.
Uh,
Greece.
And then this enormous exchange of
populations begins forced exchange of
populations as followed by,
you know,
voluntary between Turkey and Greece.
Uh,
but the,
the case of Turkey is
special because a Ataturk,
um,
whom you can read about,
you know,
he becomes the to visionary president of,
of a,
of a new Turkey,
of a secularized Turkey,
uh,
and,
and does not go the way of,
of,
uh,
for all occasional stridency of
the way of this serve Europe,
of,
of little dictators,
uh,
the eastern and central Europe of,
of little,
uh,
dictators.
And,
and even as I said,
and we check this over,
where are we?
I kind of left my lecture behind,
but that's all right.
I'm doing the themes that,
that we should be doing anyway,
and you can read it,
but the rest,
um,
that,
even Czechoslovakia,
you,
no one can say,
well,
there was of a democracy that really,
truly function.
Uh,
but there,
there are enormous tensions
and Czechoslovakia as well
because what you've got,
you've got your checks and your
checks are the dominant population in
Czechoslovakia,
but they are basically Protestant,
mostly Protestant.
Uh,
to check part or would it become the
Czech Republic is as you already know?
Uh,
largely Bohemia,
well,
much of it is Bohemia.
There's Moravia also,
it was just my poor,
but,
uh,
it is very industrial.
It is much more pro pro,
uh,
more pro,
a prosperous and then Slovakia is almost
entirely Catholic and much more rural.
Uh,
it's basically a peasant society in which
the Catholic Church and particularly
the very right wing aspects of the
Catholic Church as opposed to the case of
Poland,
I where the Catholic Church has
basically been a force for progress.
I saw except for,
you know,
antisemitic currents in
some parts of the clergy.
And it's not surprising
that our world war two,
when the,
you know,
the most horrendous collaborators
and people cheering on,
you know,
uh,
the guards of the,
of,
of the Jews is they're putting,
packing them onto the
train can be taken away.
Killed.
I was a priest.
Uh,
uh,
and again,
I mean this is,
I'm not dissing the Catholic church.
I was raised at a Jesuit high school,
uh,
and again,
but,
uh,
but there were tensions
with it within a checklist.
The lucky also that even in the victor,
you know,
the,
in the triumphant case,
I mean triumphant until,
you know,
the German legions start marching in
and then they start killing Jews again
there,
uh,
or they'd not again,
because it really hadn't been been
in a program and stuff like that.
They're,
uh,
um,
was,
was even there.
The,
that,
it's the complexity of,
of the whole thing that is simply,
um,
you know,
it's simply amazing,
but the big point,
it's not big news,
but the,
but the big point is that contentions,
a contested borders,
uh,
the diplomatic problems,
caused by the,
uh,
or inherent in having these new states,
Czechoslovakia,
Poland,
and Yugoslavia.
Uh,
we'll,
uh,
we'll continue to,
um,
to,
to be,
uh,
to be very important in,
in a,
in a place that had
virtually no parliamentary,
uh,
traditions.
Um,
there is,
there,
there aren't the ones we're
the democratic traditions in,
in,
uh,
even in a country like Poland,
which had been divided up
between these three empires.
So it was pretty hard,
darn hard to suddenly say,
well,
now we are a,
you know,
we are a republic and try
to try to make that work.
Um,
it's very,
very different difficult indeed.
You know,
there's a mistake in that,
in that book,
uh,
or at least I Polish friends told me
it's a mistake as I have described
Pilsudski Pil Sud ski who,
um,
whose parents and who he himself thought
he was a Lithuanian at the beginning,
but I already talked about that.
He's described as being right wing.
He began his career as
being kind of left wing,
but he's the first to destroy,
uh,
a parliamentary regime
and he does that in 1926,
uh,
fuel zoots Keith,
a great hero in Poland still,
I was taken on a,
you know,
almost a forced march to see his tomb.
Uh,
and,
uh,
why?
Because he in the miracle
of this tool or river,
the stool is monumentally
important river in,
in Poland that the,
that,
that the Red Army,
uh,
you know,
Trotsky's Red Army is moving toward
Warsaw and imagining that they're going to
move toward Berlin and assist this rush,
the revolution in Germany.
And they're turned back
in the suburbs of Warsaw,
the miracle of the Vistula by Pilsudski.
And of course,
this gives him a kind of a prestige and
identification with the Polish state.
Uh,
that is obviously important.
And so he,
um,
in 1926,
he says,
look,
this,
this is impossible.
He puts an end to the
parliamentary regime,
at least in reality.
And then of course,
the night he's a 19,
29 or 1930,
uh,
he,
he rested,
he arrests the,
you know,
the progressive opposition.
So he behaves like these other dictators.
It's up.
He's not putting people against the wall,
you know,
and,
uh,
or beating them to death and stuff,
having a beaten to death by,
by,
uh,
iron guards and all these,
these,
uh,
these groups.
Um,
so,
uh,
that,
that's one of the first to go.
Now compounding all of this is the,
again,
to go back what I said at the
beginning is that eastern Europe,
East Central Europe,
incidentally,
the polls no longer want to see themselves
as described as the eastern Europe.
And then it was east central Europe and
they said you should go through your
book and take out all references to
eastern Europe with regard Poland.
Um,
we are central Europe and they look,
they,
you know,
that's how they see themselves.
And again,
it's,
it,
it's impossible to overestimate the
hatred and still the fear of uh,
uh,
of Russia.
And that's why they had this ridiculous
idea of having American basis in,
in Poland,
which is just a crazy idea.
But anyway,
that's just my personal opinion
and in in a parentheses.
But compounding,
all of this is the fit.
You've got a peasant society.
All of these are peasant societies.
The vast majority of the
population are peasants.
I think it's about 75%
in Poland and Poland.
Warsaw is already very big crop office.
Very,
very big.
Keep talking about Poland
cause that's the one I know I,
I know the best,
but a Buddha and hungry would be
less because Budapest is so sad.
It's such a large city.
And also lots of the rural parts
of Hungary had been amputated,
but it's a peasant society.
And what brings,
and this is the argument of,
of my,
uh,
a good friend,
Kim Snyder,
uh,
what brings peasants into politics in
the 1920s is one thing besides hating
people might have the same ethnic
group was them depending on the place.
And,
and uh,
maybe being antisemitic because of their
tradition of rural money lenders and
all this who happened to be Jewish
and Jewish store keepers in,
in their perception,
in the peasant perception of the world,
uh,
is the hope of land reform,
of land reform,
of maybe breaking up
the biggest states and,
and,
and uh,
but at a minimum helping
out poor rural people.
And what happens is that in the 1920s,
in the 1930s,
is that poor rural people are being
screwed and put it crudely by what?
By the agricultural depression.
Because the price of,
of,
uh,
agricultural products,
which is the economy is the,
uh,
plunges to practically nothing,
and,
um,
they can't get by.
And,
um,
one of the factors for
the rise of fascism,
uh,
in all of its guises,
this called fascism,
Italy,
it's called national socialism in,
in,
uh,
um,
you know,
in Germany,
uh,
it's called,
it's called shrunk keys and men in a,
why this we call in French
and we call in English in,
in,
uh,
um,
in Spain.
No,
that's,
he's not really a fascist.
He's a right.
Frank was a right wing authoritarian,
still a murderer,
but he's a right wing authoritarian.
Uh,
but he's still a murderer.
A period,
um,
is,
uh,
is the economic situation,
and I'll make this clear
when I talk about Germany,
uh,
because that's what
drives the middle class,
which is,
are the first class to embrace Hitler.
Um,
it's the big crisis of,
uh,
of the great inflation in the early 1920s.
And what helps drive,
uh,
drive peasants to all of these countries,
the ones who become
politicized and finally say,
well,
you know,
what a parliamentary
regime bring me my family.
Not much.
We just still can't,
we can't get by.
Um,
so,
uh,
well,
ah,
uh,
these little dictator
guys thundering away,
they seem to be telling it like it is.
It's the Jews or it's the Bulgarians.
There's the Romanians or it's
Hungarians or it's that serves her.
It's a,
you name.
It was the Muslims.
It's,
yeah,
it's the Greeks.
It's the Turks.
I mean,
you,
you name it,
you know,
you fill in the fill in the,
that national group and it's a Europe
of hatred and to Europe of fear
and absorbed integrated fear.
I suppose that's kind of
a silly way of putting it,
but not that,
not that,
not that bad.
After all.
And when they look around,
what do they see the first,
you know,
the,
these countries are your other frightened.
They,
they uh,
they,
the,
these powers,
the new states,
they lie.
They say,
well,
we're going to have to lie together.
And you know,
some of them join up with France
and that won't do much good in 1939.
Um,
but there is this model that seems to
be working in Germany and the France,
what they do in this inflation
and 1920s and thirties,
you know,
they've,
they were loaning money everywhere.
You know,
before they know,
they pull in the reins,
they ring in the credit
and Nazi Germany,
particularly after it is Nazi Germany,
after January,
1933 they provide the sort
of model and they say,
well look,
you know,
we'll help you out.
We'll help you out.
We'll,
we'll the other countries are not buying
your products will buy even more of
them and we'll loan you money
and we'll organize this.
And it seems to be an orderly
society and more about that.
It's not just a society of
coercion a without jumping ahead.
You know,
Hitler seems to be providing
things to the German people that,
that,
that they want a work.
I mean,
the armaments factories,
he's preparing for war order,
you know,
they're resting petty criminals.
I'll talk more about
that and racial purity.
And they begin thinking,
Hey,
that's a good thing.
It's the fault of the Jews and the Poles.
It's,
it's the fault of the Poles.
And you know,
when they,
when they invade Poland,
uh,
this,
I don't emphasize this as much
as I should have been in your,
um,
in your book,
but,
uh,
you know,
they,
they begin right away,
uh,
carrying out a genocide.
Uh,
they begin killing the
Polish intelligentsia,
uh,
right away,
and they kill the Polish
a generals right away.
Uh,
and the Russians are doing
the same thing actually,
uh,
the Soviets a further on.
And so,
uh,
this is a,
it's a,
it's a permanent source of instability.
This agrarian,
uh,
depression does economic,
depression.
But what it does,
it's a factor for further destabilization
and talk about parliamentary regimes
comes pretty cheap,
but they,
they disappear one after another.
And in each and every
case in the fascist and,
and variance in each and every case,
uh,
the discourse is we,
the real people of this place.
We do not want these other people here.
We don't want them here.
And of course not all of
these people carried it to,
uh,
to the,
to,
uh,
the,
the outcome of,
uh,
of the Nazis or of the Lithuanians and
the Ukrainians who just started beating,
beating Jews to death
and all along the way.
But,
but,
uh,
it wasn't just the western
states that had great,
uh,
instability,
and the willingness and the
eagerness of people like who are,
need to collaborate with,
uh,
with Hitler openly,
enthusiastically,
uh,
all the way through until the bitter end,
as in part a result of,
of,
uh,
that,
that these right wing movements
become mass movements in these places.
And,
and as they did in,
in Germany,
in,
uh,
you know,
8% of the population of,
of the Netherlands votes
for their guy called Musa,
who's their little fascist sky,
uh,
or in,
in Belgium,
in which is town of shopkeepers.
They support their guy who just
died about 10 years ago lug well,
who's a,
who's a good luck,
I can't remember what his name was.
Uh,
who died in the Costa Brava.
They all seem to dine in the Costa Brava.
They all basically get away with it and
ended up going to Spain in a lot of them
protected by the Franco regime.
And they all seem to
Croak on the Costa Brava.
But,
uh,
anyway,
well,
I got away from the text,
but it doesn't matter.
I didn't really,
I,
uh,
I think I've made my points anyway.
And the points are that,
that,
uh,
that Europe is in a period of unstability
of instability that with the exception
of the big powers in the
West between 1924 in 1929,
uh,
all of these places are in depression.
Uh,
and that the sweeping away
of parliamentary regimes,
uh,
in places that had virtually no
parliamentary traditions at all,
uh,
was not all that surprising
and that it was compounded by,
uh,
the outcome of World War One.
Uh,
that again,
as I've said before,
at least twice that the demons of the,
of the 20th century,
you know,
emerged from the war and
nowhere more tellingly,
more appallingly with greater,
uh,
with greater costs,
with greater devastation,
with,
uh,
humanities thinking to an
all time low than that in,
in a Nazi Germany.
And that's what I'm
going to talk about next.
Uh,
Wednesday,
Monday,
another cheerful topic,
stolen Islam.
Uh,
and,
uh,
we will go from there.
Have a wonderful weekend and I'll see you.